hey guys it's max and vadim and today we
are doing another blind comparison I
shot a series of images and video clips
on all of these phones right here and
we're gonna find out is the s20 ultra
actually the best smartphone camera as
you guys know Samsung marketed this
phone like crazy and their biggest focus
were the cameras you guys could see the
difference in bumps here because I want
to know is it actually that much better
than the note 10 plus which came out
half a year ago or even the cheaper
alternative to s 20 plus now Before we
jump in I do want to say that what deem
is gonna be choosing the one he likes
the best so he's gonna get a score we
don't know what you're gonna get which
one is the best overall but I actually
went through and rated all of the phones
in a blind fashion as well zero out of
five zero for a failed photo five the
best you can get for a smart phone these
days and let me tell you I was really
kind of surprised by the results and
I'll give you guys the strengths and the
weaknesses of all these phones which
they all have so you guys don't want us
out on our findings so Vadim which one
do you like the best so I can already
tell that this is going to be a very
very tough comparison the whole video is
because these are so similar they all
look really good they look great but
what I'm noticing is that the one in the
middle I think has better dynamic range
I like the white balance on the the
grass the hay right there and I think
there's less flaring from the Sun right
over there so middle right there Center
no Guzman are you kidding I actually
forgot although I'm on a lot of these I
forgot was one and these are flipped
around Wow yeah and you guys out there
pull out your phone get a piece of paper
and Mark which one you like best so
we'll see not only which one Vadim likes
best which one i rated overall which is
surprising to me and you guys as well
here's number two so I was thinking of
going with the center again but I don't
really like how it's pretty flat so I
think the one on the right has I guess
better contrast better colors so that
one that's twenty plus twenty plus I'm
definitely going with the one in the
center because the HDR is better like
the the inside the interior is brought
up a lot higher out more so I like that
one better that way yeah this is the one
out I would want
if I took a real-estate shot not these
other two surprising I like that the one
on the right doesn't have as much
flaring and the contrast is really nice
but the clouds are all blown out the
skies will announce so honestly it's
such a tough choice but I'm gonna go
with the center no ten plus I have to
say that I updated all of the firmer on
all these phones right before shooting
all these so this is the latest and
greatest and now for our first video
clip this is all 4k recording and take a
look let me know you like best well what
was that oh man
okay that one on the left for sure that
looks amazing no focus hunting the
detail looks surprisingly better than
the others so left I think okay no as
the note 10 plus what's going on as you
saw that's 20 ultra has a lot of focus
hunting and pulsing s 20 plus is way
better at that no 10 plus is perfect me
because the software updates are
different lenses or Sony sensors each
star is better - yeah it looks good so
with this one even though like right
here we have some blown out detail right
here I like that the shadows are brought
up more and it looks like the water is a
little bit more bright compared to the
other two which are a little bit dim so
Center again no sin plus and I should
add in that this is using the ultra
lights which this one is a 16 megapixel
compared to 12 so with this portrait
shot I'm seeing that the one on the left
is a little bit dim the one in the
center is a little bit overexposed but
it does have more detail so I'm gonna go
with the right for being a good middle
ground that's 20 plus so here I
instantly notice that the one on the
left is completely blown out in the sky
area there's no detail at all so between
the center and the right it's a really
tough call
but the one in the middle has better HDR
that's 20 plus that's 20 how do you got
it all try yet No
I have it you have a ghost come on I'll
try come on camera bump what'd he do so
the clouds are blown out on all three of
them but I am seeing some some flaring
or some kind of lack of contrast here in
the center so I think I'm gonna go with
the right s1e all true yes you had a
first one nice you redeemed yourself
West 2003 and this one is our second
video clip this is at 4k 60 here okay so
I saw a little bit of like shake on the
right I don't know what that was or
maybe I was hunting or something I think
the best one was in the center s20 ultra
again back to photos this is the same
situation but photos and it's a very
very tough dynamic range shot definitely
the one in the center you could actually
see the rock detail and everything else
HDR is good to note 10 plus and this is
a trend as you guys are seeing from the
indoor real estate shot whereas it just
the sky detail is still very good when
we see way more in the shadows very
interesting here's another video shot
this is testing stabilization at 4k 60 I
will say for KI 30 they were identical
so I didn't include that to make this
house longer but this is 4k 60 so the
one on the left is like super shaky
between the middle and the right it's
pretty tough but I'm seeing more shake
and more motion blur I guess in the
center so I'm going with the right okay
so another one for the s 20 plus so in
this photo right away I can instantly
tell that the center one is the winner
at much more detail less aliasing so
that's got to be the s20 ultra you are
right telephoto lens definitely the best
what do you think about this one
alright so to be honest I'm gonna go
with the one on the left even though it
doesn't have as much detail the one in
the center has a lot of noise in his
face and same with the right so left
there
what no 10 plus so the no 10 plus uses a
16 megapixel sensor but it just looks
like it's a lot less artifacting least
two which use a new 12 megapixel and
here is the original shot I did punch in
quite a bit something to just check you
know the quality of the ultra wide this
one definitely the center again just so
much more detail yeah that's a mass
difference and that is the s20 ultra but
there's a trick for this one this is
actually a standard shot taken using the
hundred eight megapixel mode yeah
because you can choose to do 108
megapixels on here instead of over
binning to 12 megapixel so I wanted to
test that out these two are 12 okay so
we see a big difference comparing them
and this is what it looks like if we use
the pixel bidding mode to go to 12 so
people are saying if you're going from
one way to 12
it still looks way more detailed than
just shooting 12 but I'm not seeing that
the s20 ultra it looks the same it looks
very similar I'm seeing a little bit
more lines here maybe a little bit less
artifacting but little bit more less
detail and even and this one's a little
bit worse so it's very interesting so if
you want to shoot an image this is a
full shot that's the knowing if you want
to get the best detail use the 180
megapixel if you have an ultra but if
you're not gonna be zooming in that much
it doesn't matter because even on a 6k
screen you can't tell the difference yet
from here and then there is one downside
though if you're using that mode bam if
you notice the dynamic range went down
when we switched really so we have less
detail in the shadows more of the clouds
are blown out the sky is blown out so
resides it down you get more detail the
less HDR and then the file size 25
megabytes compared to about five it goes
to 25 now here's another video I'm not
gonna tell you exactly what is going on
but you look at the differences for
yourself and then let me know what you
see overall what's the difference and
which one looks better to you what I
notice while watching these two Clips is
that the one in the center and on the
right how this weird stuttering where
it's like kind of jagged II as it's
moving over to the right so I think the
one on the left is the one I'm choosing
okay note 10-plus I don't know why this
guy messed up here that is the mono ten
plus and this is another kind of tricky
one both the s20 ultra and the plus u8k
so no ten plus is shooting 4k 30 where
these are shooting a K now you notice
that jittering cuz these can only shoot
at 24 frames per second did you notice
any difference in detail when you were
watching that not by much honestly the
4k video from the note 10 is actually
not 4k I had to zoom in 1.3 five times
or so in order to match how they look
because these cropping automatically so
it's not more like 3k vs. 8k and looking
at a 6k XDR display it's barely any
difference and I was not expecting that
here obviously the one on the left is so
much more detail than the other two no
way no 10 plus s20 ultra if you want to
do two times zoom which is what this is
it has to crop in on the sensor and even
though it's 108 megapixels it still
looks a lot worse yep same thing here
the one on the left is more detailed it
looks like and there's less noise as
well than the other two tries an actual
long zoom and here's another video I'll
take a look tons of noise on the one on
the left and the right the one in the
center is more clean and it's more
detailed as 20 Ultra ultra in this
portrait shot they literally look almost
identical like I have to look really
close and if I do I think I see more
detail on the left I'm going with that
one yeah no tablets plus there there's
so close guys in this one I was shocked
in this shot of the flowers it looks
like the one in the center like the
flowers look really flat not much
contrast the one on the left are a
little bit like overexposed the one on
the right there is a couple of issues
with the blurring but I'm just seeing so
much more detail compared to the others
everywhere here that I would still
choose that one is 20 plus in this one
I'm gonna choose the one in the center
I'm seeing quite a bit more detail and I
guess better dynamic range so 110 plus
so this is actually a 4x shot which is
perfect for the s20 ultra cuz as a 4x
optical lens where these two have to
crop digitally twice but because the
lens lets in a lot less light in lower
light situations it produces worse
results in s20 ultra has a 64 mega
megapixel sensor this is only 12 how is
that possible and it's still light
lighting basically it's
did a better job I'm coming with the one
in the center here because I guess
better dynamic range I can see more
detail in my hair this one's kind of
blurry this one has too much contrast so
Center and now for a low-light portrait
selfie honestly it's kind of tough
between the middle and the right but I'm
gonna go which one would you want to
save yeah they're you know 10 plus and
now we are getting into some video shots
this is low-light 4k video okay alright
so I'm seeing that the white balance is
really messed up on the left and there's
more noise in the center than on the
right it seems like and I like the
colors better and detail better on the
right place occultation s2000 and then
this one right here is using the optical
lens this is the using the telephoto
lens here okay under this letter I don't
know what happened the one on the left
has massive amounts of noise in the one
on the right is the winner probably yep
that's 20 plus again what this is same
layout once again this is a four time
zoom so that's 20 Ultra is the only one
that actually has a four time zoom lens
use but even with though it has that
advantage because of lighting it looks
way worse now let's get into night shots
this one is pretty tough but I'm
noticing that it's a little bit
overexposed here on the left on that
sign and the one in the center has more
detail really great HDR at that one s20
and this is another one using the ultra
wide lens I'm seeing a lot of noise in
the center in between the left and the
right I think I'm gonna go with the left
that has more detail that's 20 Ultra and
this is a night mode selfie selfie
alright the one on the left has a lot of
blur motion blur in between the center
and the right so I'm gonna go with the
center it looks more sharp
notes ten plus and this is a night mood
shot with the telephoto lens the one in
the center just got completely ruined
somehow the one on the right has a lot
of noise so left s 2020 Plus this is
standard lens and I do want to say this
is on the tripod so this one is really
easy the one in the center just looks so
much better than the others that's 20
I was surprised somebody + yep and
ultra-wide this one is a little bit more
tough than the other one but I think I
like the colors better on the centre
ultra and as you guys might have noticed
the no 10 plus is really struggling when
it's on a tripod for night mode shots
yeah this is all software I gotta say
the other ones took 30 seconds or 28
seconds each for all these photos okay
the note 10 pleasantly took 5 if the
software is not letting it do longer
exposures so if samsung can fix it it
could be a lot better cuz it's really
bad in these shots and that is it that's
it that is it okay um go ahead count
this up all right so I got 13 for the
note 10 plus I got 9 for the s 20 plus
and 10 for the ultra I was not expecting
that one whoa
yeah the note 1 whatever one even mourn
or got closer if it didn't have the for
the low-light shots the limitation to 5
seconds let's go ahead and give you my
results of what I got so as you guys
know I mentioned at the start okay
that I rated each image from a zero to
five scale zero unusable 5 the best you
can expect from a smartphone and then I
added all this up and averaged it out
and I got a 3.93 for the note three
point I got a four point one for the
ultra and I got a four point three three
stars out of five for the plus now I
want to say that I was watching on a 6k
display taking my time pixel peeping out
at different things not on the laptop
and what's interesting is that the ultra
got two ones I didn't get any zeros but
I got two ones on the ultra and two ones
in the notes but the s20 plus I didn't
get any ones what it shows me is just
really well-rounded in a lot of
scenarios the note 10 plus you got as
first place it was first where it really
lost the most points was those low-light
shots a lot of those long exposures in
like I mentioned yeah it can't do more
than five seconds so it's just a
software limitation of Samsung put onto
it which can be fixed with an update so
if they change make those changes or
some of the portrait changes it could be
even better so is the s20 ultra the best
smartphone that Samsung makes as far as
cameras they spent so much time talking
about the cameras during the keynote
marketing and pushing it I don't think
so no it certainly does some things well
like in the daytime with that zoom lens
and some of the 108 megapixel shots it
clearly does that but it also has some
big limitations like the auto focusing
issues it has and there's a couple other
things I did want to point out that's
not in this video we didn't want to put
in the test but if you want to do macro
shots with the telephoto that typically
look really good that telephoto can't
get as close as these other two as
twenty-plus as an excellent job and
along with that if you're taking
pictures of documents some close-up
shots this is what I found just in my
everyday shooting it has some issues
we're in the mid hero the media is in
focus and as we go to the edges it's
really blurred out and out of focus
there's some kind of lens issues s20
plus is better but it has a little bit
of that whereas the older a little bit
smaller sensor note 10 plus it's all on
focus all in focus the lens quality is
very good so that was a very interesting
fine so very interesting results let us
know what you guys got down in the
comment section below which one did you
get was the best did any of this
surprise you and if you were choosing
one of these for your money which
smartphone would you get if you want
take good pictures and video thank you
guys for watching click that little
circle above to subscribe and check out
our other videos on these phones right
over there is some max and Verdean and
we'll see you in the next video
you
[Music]